that's going past the Household Cavalry
Regiment base at Knightsbridge but I
think we're seeing quite a stop here
just outside there seems to be a drama
with one of the motorcycles in the
distance yeah it looks like there could
be some kind of human change we think
people are trying to stop this arrival
and the police are obviously intervening
Rhiannon Mills is here you've got the
statement from the Palatine yes while we
watch these images in which the
panelists have said the right honourable
treasom a MP had an audience of the
Queen this afternoon and tendered her
resignation as Prime Minister and First
Lord of the Treasury which Her Majesty
was graciously pleased to accept so that
first moment about handover and power
has happened as we now see Boris Johnson
heading towards Thoris Johnson just
comes behind us in the car behind us
right now not without incident his
arrival at the palace it was a climate
emergency protest we saw from the
banners there that they put across the
mall there tried to stop his convoy
coming in this is the end of here at him
arriving at us a civilian as it were and
he will still be a civilian as prime
minister but but from when he steps out
of this car when he comes back out of
this building Alistair he he will be
Prime Minister that's right I mean
normally you expect to not have a
motorcycle rider escort coming to the
palace but I'm very glad it happened
today after seeing that there was a
challenge there there now in side the
Quadrangle within the palace and turning
to a halt at the King's door Boris
Johnson MP having been selected by the
conservative part of its new leader is
coming to see the Queen responding to
her summons and he will be invited to
form a government received by the a
query
and the private secretary to the Queen
Edward Young who forms part of the
principle